foreign
Panettiere's brother Jansen has died he
was 28 years old
art expression is the key to the soul to
me you know I need it I don't know where
I would be without art Jansen died over
the weekend in New York and while no
official cause of death has been
released no foul plays been suspected
et's reached out to Hayden's Reps for
comment
Jansen like his older sister was an
actor my family grew up in it they're
all performers and it became it came
easy to me you know I just you know most
people do what they're good at and I
happen to be good at running my mouth
some of his many roles in the early
2000s included Even Stevens and The
Walking Dead good thing we're headed to
the fair y'all could live it up there
Jansen even starred alongside his sister
in movies like racing stripes and tiger
cruise we did a Disney Channel film
called tiger Cruise
um and it's always fun uh working with
my sister because she I get a lot of my
acting from her and from my mom so it's
really nice working with someone who's
in the scene who can really help you out
and I feel very comfortable acting
around her so she really brings out the
best in me and uh because I'm her
brother I kind of I think I kind of
bring out the best in her which is nice
Jansen survived by Hayden and their
parents Leslie and skip
foreign